all right so thank you james
and i want to first give a disclaimer
even though i know you should never
start with a disclaimer this is a brand
new talk i just finished the slides this
morning that means i have no idea what's
going to happen um and that has three no
that means three things for all of you
um one is that i may stumble and get
lost don't laugh at me two is that i may
say things that make no sense raise your
hand and tell me i just said something
that makes no sense um and three is that
i'm going to try to leave a lot of um a
lot of time for questions and discussion
at the end because um like i said i'm
not sure if this stuff makes sense or
not this is my attempt to take some work
that my group has been doing over the
past few years and try to figure out why
it's interesting to me and why we keep
doing it
and i would very much welcome your input
on the way that whether the way that
we're thinking about this makes sense or
not so please take notes
if i finish early don't go home
i would love to discuss it
so i'm going to start with this image
which is sort of a cliche image of
internet network whatever and i bring it
up to remind you of a time that
hopefully most of you remember
on the order 15 or 20 years ago when we
tended to think of the internet as this
separate space where we would interact
with people who we met online and we
would um do so primarily anonymously
this was famously in the title for this
talk as a reference to this new yorker
cartoon where two dogs are sitting there
and one of them says on the internet
nobody knows you're a dog and at the
time this was really true right because
you were talking to people who really
didn't know anything about you you were
talking to people who didn't know where
you were
and you could really do a lot and cheri
turkel in her book called life on screen
made a very similar point more words
fewer dogs but fundamentally arguing
that you could experiment with
identities you could play with
stigmatized identities you could try on
new things and she chronicled a lot of
people who were doing this in
different kinds of game playing
environments different kinds of
discussion groups online um and there
was a lot of this going on there were
also people who
as you know this notion of the internet
is a separate space where we could talk
to anybody and do stuff with anybody in
the world
folks predicted the distance was not
going to matter in the future we were
going to work with everybody we were
going to interact with everybody and it
was going to be great
but of course that's not how it happened
and we all know
just from living in the world today
hopefully you realize that location
turns out to matter a great deal
and part of this is a function of the
fact that now we've all got one of these
that we carry with us and it knows where
we are and it can relay that information
to the network and that turns out to be
very useful in a number of ways so we
can do stuff like check in on foursquare
and tell our friends where we are so
they can find us or find find out
information about us we can leave
information for strangers we can tell
them when we ate at a good restaurant so
that when they approach that good
restaurant and they open up yelp they'll
say oh look this is a good restaurant
that's a useful thing to do we can also
meet other people we can meet strangers
who are nearby who perhaps want some
sort of romantic encounter or social
encounter or friendship with tools like
tinder
or in the case of a tool that i'll be
talking about
a bit more in a couple of minutes grindr
which is known for connecting connecting
gay men who want to have sexual
encounters with with each other
and in fact there's some evidence to
suggest that people are do people are
using these tools to meet other people a
lot
so if you look at some survey data on
how did couples meet
and we look at data for opposite sex
couples for example
so here we see the ways different each
of these lines is a different way that
people met the important things you want
to look at is that these red triangles
indicate couples that met online which
for opposite sex couples goes up to
about 20 percent kind of stabilizes
around 2010 this is data that was
released a couple years ago so we don't
have current data you see that meeting
people through friends goes down at a
similar at a similar rate
and then when we look at the same data
for same-sex couples and this is one of
the reasons i find this interesting in
this community look at the red triangles
there
um so why might that be well there are a
lot of reasons but one um
noteworthy reason is that if you're a
guy and you're into women
it's most of the time pretty easy to
figure out who women are right not
always um whether they're single or not
etcetera these are problems that um
still need to be solved but you can
figure out who the women are at least
whereas if you're a guy who's into other
guys it's easy to spot the guys um but a
relatively small fraction of them are
likely to be interested in people like
you and so you need to figure out who
those people are and well tools like
grinder give them a really easy way to
do that and so that i would argue is one
of the reasons why we see this huge
spike in men meeting other men
or people of the same sex meeting other
people of the same sex meeting each
other online
and this is also the reason that i'm
going to be focusing primarily on grindr
which is a tool used by gay men
predominantly
because i think this is a community that
brings this issue of meeting strangers
nearby into relief in useful ways
question so i get that argument well it
surprised me from what that is you would
think for example bar like
gay bar kind of serves a similar purpose
to say you know who other people are
but i mean gay bars tend to occur in
places that are that have a dense gate
community already
um which is not
a lot of places and you're only there a
pretty small fraction of the time um do
you know if um online
has necessarily replaced
the other things or are there just more
ways to meet people
yeah
yeah i mean certainly it seems like
meeting through friends goes down quite
a bit um bars kind of spikes up a little
bit which is actually a little bit
surprising though i can talk about some
reasons why that why that might be too
um but yeah that that i'm not sure about
in terms of how much exclusive these are
but it's a good that's a good question
um but anyway so that's that's why i'm
going to be focusing on grindr here
because it brings these issues into
inter-relief and use in some useful ways
and to think first about this question
so coming back to this idea of location
mattering um and anonymity being
something that we sort of have but we
sort of don't have and i want to make
the argument that anonymity when people
are
when people are um
anonymity when people are in the same
place and they know that others are in
the same place is going to look a lot
different than anonymity in the sort of
on the internet nobody knows you're a
dog age and there are a number of
reasons for that and i'm going to
explore them in a bit more depth as a
way to think about this research
question of how do location that is
knowing where other people are and this
idea that we're in the same location and
having awareness of that information
and identity that is how am i portraying
myself and what a identity am i trying
to assume in this space
going to intersect in location-aware
social applications such as grindr
so for those who are not familiar with
grindr here is an image of what it looks
like basically you log in it shows you a
bunch of people who are nearby
shows you a photo at first these are
sorted in order of their physical
proximity to you so the closest one well
so you're the very top left you're
justin in this case then lance is the
closest and so on and so forth
if you tap on one of them because you
think they look interesting then they'll
bring up their profile
tells you how far away they are in feet
or meters if you're in a metric country
how old they are some stats that they
can choose to review there's a free text
field where you can provide some dropbox
around that
there's a free text field where you can
provide some information and then if you
decide yes this is an interesting person
that i would like to interact with more
then you can tap on the chat button and
you get a conversation this is a bit
more vacuous than most grinder chats but
not by much
and so people can um
people can talk to each other
um and so there are a couple things to
take away from this right one is the
grinder showing you the um
the people who are closest to you
which means that the extent to which any
one person is visible is going to depend
a lot on density and of course the the
number of people that you see is going
to depend a bit on density so this is in
um this is sort of a simulation of
boys town in chicago which is a
predominantly gay neighborhood and in
this case the farthest person away was
about 1300 feet
um if you ran this in
rural nebraska say it would look a lot
different the closest person might be 70
or 80 miles away um in some cases so the
number the
the amount of space that you're going to
be looking at and i'll see more about
this in a minute is going to vary with
the number of other people who are
logged in
and essentially i should say that what
it's doing is it's showing you people
who have been signed in in the last hour
so this projector doesn't really show
them some of these people are grayed out
there's a little gray face there it's a
great one there
what that means is that those are people
who are in that space but they haven't
logged in with the last hour so you're
not gonna um you're not gonna see them
as active and so
so the the implication of that is that
if we look at a neighborhood like boys
town in chicago
and we want to um
and
essentially we might see in a place like
this we might see people who are in a
radius about 1300 feet which is about
what that looks like
and
importantly this is going to cross a
whole bunch of boundaries so this is of
course one neighborhood in chicago but
within that neighborhood there are some
spaces that look very different so for
example there is a starbucks an
environment you're probably all familiar
with um and there is also a steamworks
bath house which is an environment that
is very different from starbucks um some
of you may be familiar with but if
you're in a bath house and you're
running grinder the context that you're
in is going to look very different than
starbucks but grinder's essentially
putting you both in the same place and
that has some implications so we're both
in the same geographic area generally
and we're both on grinder together but
we're in very different real world
contexts and that that matters in ways
that i'm going to talk about
um and then the other thing is just
because um and i hinted at this earlier
just because in boys town the radius is
1300 feet doesn't necessarily mean that
that's true if i look at it in evanston
for example that's northwestern that's
where our campus is um so there the
radius well it includes a lot of fish
they're not signed in on grinder but um
but there the radius might include some
north shore suburbs and it might go down
as far as
north
north chicago and so you might see it
for people as far away as four or five
miles
and that's going to have some
implications too because suddenly it may
be important
because grinder just tells me that
you're a quarter mile away right it
doesn't tell me that you are in winnetka
or um rogers park and those are two
really different places and that's going
to affect possibly how what i'm going to
think about you because we we have
inferences that we based on where people
live in different neighborhoods and so
on and so forth and it's also and it's
going to make that potentially more
confusing because i'm going to know less
about you and so we may see people try
to correct for that question so when it
reveals those people near me and i click
on them i don't get any further
information about where they are at all
so all you get is their distance
okay so david for example is 463 feet
away um 400 feet in any given direction
is not a big deal 40 miles in any given
direction that's a lot more ambiguity
right and so that turns out to um that
turns out to matter do they try to um
have some constant number of people in
that circle yeah so you're gonna have
about a hundred people okay yeah so
you're gonna have a circle that's big
enough to enclose about or take that
back 50 in the new version
um so we've got studying this in a
couple different ways so first i'm going
to tell you about some interviews that
we did so we did about 36
interviews with people who use grindr
nine of those were in you can tell that
i moved um nine of those were in or near
ithaca new york and 27 of those were in
or near um chicago illinois um people
were 19 to 55 years old median 24
they're 100 male because that's who uses
the app we weren't trying to stereotype
we recruited them using the app so we
put up the university logo and said hey
we're recruiting people for a study
please participate
and this is work that was done by
two people so courtney blackwell who
surprised a lot of people by being a
woman
on grindr when she was recruiting for
this study who's a grad student at
northwestern um as a fun side note
courtney's primary area of research is
children is children in media so she has
a cv that includes one article about
grindr and then a whole bunch about
sesame street and it's amazing
and then the other person who actually
gets a lot of credit for this work is
charlie abbott who was a north
northwestern or a cornell rather
undergrad who wrote his honors thesis on
grinder users and actually started me on
this whole line of research and
convinced me that it was a useful space
to play in um and
that's had an effect
so he gets a lot of credit for this
so let's talk about some of the things
that people told us
so one thing is that i mentioned that
grinder brings people together and we're
going to call that co-situating that is
we're going to put people together we're
going to situate people in the same sort
of virtual space even though they're in
different um even though they're in
different real world spaces and this is
going to have a few different
implications um and these are all
pseudonyms but so jim um tells us and
this is a great quote he says what i
like about grinder is that it makes
every space potentially gay space gay
men have plenty of spaces much more than
other people but there's a lot of places
that are still heterosexual and grinder
gives me the chance to pull out my phone
and have a gay bar in my pocket
and so this idea that even though he's
in one bar and somebody else might be in
another bar down the street or at a
party when he opens up grindr it's like
a portable gay space essentially right
he can essentially just see who's around
him
and it doesn't matter that there are
walls it doesn't matter that they're in
different institutions whatever you can
see everybody around and that's really
useful to him so this this sense
of um the sense of being in the same
place and creating a sort of gay space
if you want is is useful
but at the same time this looks
different for different people and again
i hinted at this earlier but the density
affects their visibility and that
matters a lot
so drew for example
talks about a time that he logged into
grindr when he was in his hometown he
was um a student when he went to his
hometown which was a much smaller town
um
everybody knew he was new so he says um
so the minute i logged into grinder
there it was like bam you just know
everybody was messaging me because he's
the only guy because he's the only new
guy he says and i got together with one
guy at some point and he was saying
you're like the new guy because we all
know each other and we've all
each other 10 times
and so he's suddenly very visible and
you can contrast that with the
experience of john who uses grinder
primarily in chicago where he's talking
about the difference of even within
chicago seeing variation in different
neighborhoods where
um
as you move down l-stops for example you
see sort of different kinds of guys so
john says when i'm in east lakeview and
boys town it's your standard white guy
who wants another white guy who goes to
the gym all the time who has muscles
when you're here in lincoln park they
tend to be a little bit more discreet
about the orientation or their sexual
activity
so there's this notion that even as you
move through the city
there are going to be different guys and
they're going to look different and
they're going to conform to sort of
expectations around neighborhood but
they're not going to be nearly as
visible as in
in the previous case where suddenly you
log in and everybody knows that you're
new and everybody wants to um everybody
wants to see you
and not only that but visibility matters
to these people being able
being visible
matters in a couple different ways so
one
is that being seen in in this space
that is grinder actually has some
meaning and people are aware of this
meaning and that can be both positive
and negative and so
matt
who was a student and uses grinder in
his dorm
um was very sensitive about being seen
by his peers um and in particular his
peers in the dorm who he didn't want to
know that he was there
so he says i just don't want my face
like plastered up there i think there's
a lot of shaming
that sort of thing and i didn't want my
face to be up there and not notice
somebody from my dorm is either a torso
that is a pick without a head
or on the profile and not have a chance
to block them quickly so this idea that
if he saw somebody he knew he didn't
want them to know he was on grindr but
he still wanted to be there
because he was interested in meeting
other people so there's sort of a stigma
attached to casual sex in this case via
slut-shaming
but at the same time wanting to be there
and to meet other people who have the
same goal because there's sort of a
mutually assured destruction there right
but if other people see you you don't
necessarily want that so being
recognized
is potentially problematic so we see
evidence that people will recognize you
even though they're not using their real
name so this is one of the ways in which
anonymity becomes very different locally
because theoretically when you sign into
grindr you're anonymous right they don't
know your name other people don't know
your identity in the way that we tend to
think about it
but a picture can be very identifying
for people who recognize you and we've
actually heard of people in a study
we're working on analyzing right now
people actually doing a google reverse
image search on profile pics to try to
figure out who people are so there's a
lot of intelligence in the community
around identity
make yeah
where you're not seeing
what do you say
in this radius oh no i don't want to be
no no
yeah no you you sign in and you're
visible with everybody around you and
you can you can block people who will no
longer be able to see you and they can
block you okay um but that's that's it
so surprisingly that rural example
if they
kind of get to know everybody i'm sorry
they still use the app versus just some
out of channel ways of communicating
like if it's a small community
yeah i mean yeah so our sense is that um
a lot of it's used socially in small
communities so people will use it to
socially coordinate sort of see who's
around as a way of you know we're going
to this bar on friday because there may
not be a gay bar in the community so
it's a way of coordinating social
activities and we're also looking for
new people
um when somebody moves and so so that's
that's what we've seen and talking to
folks we haven't talked to a ton of
rural folks but that's that's our
general sense of what's going on there
um
so we see so we see sigma here um as i
was saying regarding his concerns around
shaming
and we see that faces are identifiers um
just as important in this case as using
your real name because people around you
are going to recognize you
but at the same time
people are not just concerned about the
negative aspect of visibility but
they're also concerned about attracting
people because ultimately that's why
they're on grindr right to meet other
people for some reason and so
max talks about picking a
photo that that
that conveys the right impression she
says you pick one photo you think you'll
look good in and more importantly what
will attract others i want others to
think i'm hot i want to be wanted to be
desired by others you have a good
picture something that shows off
something you have
so people want to look good they want to
convey the right impression but at the
same time they don't always want to be
recognized and so one thing if you sign
into grinder that you will see a lot of
is pictures that look like this
that is to say a photo that makes you
look attractive because it shows that
you have a decent body perhaps
but does not make you identifiable
because your face is not there so these
are known as headless torso picks and
they're pretty common note that this guy
says educated and very well cultured um
which is kind of an amazing contrast
and so
but at the same time people respond to
even these pictures negatively even if
it's somebody who's attractive and
there's some tension in the way that
they talk about this and so dan
says on the one hand face pictures
connote a more genuine and honest person
so this is something that he might look
for in a particular social encounter
blank pictures are cop-outs and people
are not confident etc i won't read you
all these quotes you can read them
yourselves
but there's this tension between on the
one hand wanting to be attractive on the
other hand not wanting to be identified
but on the other hand not wanting to be
perceived as just somebody who's looking
for sex right especially if you are not
necessarily doing that and people aren't
even consistent internally when they
talk about this so john for example on
the one hand he says i want to see
somebody's face and i want to show you
my face and so on because i and then he
went on to say that he's just looking
for friends he wouldn't use the app to
hook up but then later in the interview
transcript he says yeah but if i'm just
cruising to hook up if you have a
beautiful body and it's headless i don't
really care so even internally we see
this tension between people on the one
hand looking for people that they think
are going to be honest and so forth but
on the other hand
sometimes they just want to hook up and
they're they're not being consistent and
we also see this tension in the ways
that people are thinking about
presenting themselves because they want
to be attractive they don't necessarily
want to
they don't necessarily want to be
recognized at least by everybody but
they also don't want to be perceived
negatively okay
so we were interested in having talked
to people we wanted to see how this
played out in people's profiles
themselves
and so to do this we looked at the text
of grinder profiles so we um we got our
hands on not quite 70 000 of these
from college towns and from from urban
areas and we use pretty simple language
processing we use a bag of words
approach and also pattern pattern
matching
essentially on the free text fields in
people's profiles and here credit goes
partly to judd brubaker who's a grad
student at uc irvine
who got his hands on the data
and colin fitzpatrick who is a grad
student at northwestern working with me
who did a lot of the analyses that i'm
going to be talking about and is
currently working on some other work on
grindr
so these profiles have nothing to do
with what i'm talking about but just
show you an example of the diversity of
things if you want to see more go to
heyman how's it going.tumblr
but don't do that now because it will
distract you from the rest of the talk
and one of the things that we found that
was interesting when we were looking
through the
when we were looking at text and we were
running some analyses is that the most
frequent word that occurred in people's
free text profile fields was the word
looking
which is sort of this delightfully
ambiguous word because on its own
very often looking is connotes that
you're looking for sex
on the other hand a lot of people used
it with the word looking for so people
might say they're looking for love
perhaps
that they're looking around which also
connotes possible sexual activity they
might say that they're not looking to
hook up or not looking for sex or not
looking for any number of other things
and so given that this word was
occurring so often sometimes with not
sometimes without we decided to look for
words that contain
or
free text fields that contain the phrase
looking for
and compare them with free text fields
that contained the phrase not looking
for that is we could get a sense of what
it is that people are trying to identify
with and perhaps what they're trying to
identify in opposition to and what we
wound up with was this chart
um what essentially this shows you
is um so the the different the different
colors here are things that people could
be looking for or not looking for these
were among the more common so we see
hookups nsa which is a euphemism for an
abbreviation for no strings attached
which is a euphemism for casual
anonymous sex um fun which is
delightfully euphemistic and friends
also delightfully euphemistic
um and what you see
even though the colors are a little bit
mangled here what you see and the
college towns and urban locations look
pretty similar so that distinction isn't
actually very useful
what's that
the other monitors are better
okay
so um so what you see are that people
are on the whole looking for friends and
fun because gosh who's not looking for
fun right um and they're not looking for
hookups um or nsa a little bit
right so what we see is that they're
identifying in terms of euphemism
fun friends
and in opposition to potentially
stigmatized behavior hooking up
nsa
et cetera right so
this tension that we were talking about
plays out here too because people don't
want to be perceived as looking for
something that's potentially stigmatized
they do want to be perceived as looking
for something that is either euphemistic
or genuine because they could be looking
for friends
and gosh wouldn't it be fun if we went
to go see a movie we're looking for fun
so there are lots of ways that you can
that you can perceive these things that
people tended to say that they were
looking for
so recall i also said earlier that
another point um that was interesting
here is that grindr erases a lot of
boundaries between people right um that
is to say people could be sitting
sitting at starbucks they could be
sitting at steamworks they could be in
different neighborhoods etc so another
thing we were interested in is well do
people try to put location back into
grindr do they try to give us um this
sense that they are um
that they're identifying with a
particular location even though it's not
going to say exactly where they are do
they try to convey where they are
and it turns out that to some extent
they do
about 11
of the profiles that we saw use some
kind of location word and what do i mean
by that well we took the all the
different neighborhoods the names of all
the different neighborhoods um for the
cities that we had pulled data from we
took the names for of colleges and
universities in the area we took the
names of particularly common streets etc
and we used those and we found that a
lot of people tried to identify for
example as stanford student or a
northwestern student or um you know in
boys town or lincoln park etc because
these things convey meaning so people
were trying to even though grinders are
racing location people are trying to put
that back
in framing their identity so location
matters when you're looking for local
people in this way
um
another thing we saw is that people
tended to converge on language used to
describe themselves i'm partly putting
this in here because it's one of my i
get to show you one of my favorite
tables that i've ever had in a paper
ever
but about 22 percent of people used um
body descriptor words and these are
words that are used commonly in the gay
community
as a way of as a way of identifying
themselves as well so they weren't just
trying to identify with the place they
weren't just trying to identify as you
know not looking for
not looking for casual sex they were
also identifying as a particular body
type here's the table i mentioned
so you can see how frequently these
different um these different terms occur
but these are essentially different ways
of identifying
what you look like
body type and so forth
okay
so that's first couple studies um so
we've learned a couple things from um
from thinking about grinder in this way
so one that's interesting is that
grinder in contrast to a lot of social
tools that we tend to think about
is most valuable when nearby strangers
are using it but not when your friends
are using it because they might
recognize you and then suddenly they'd
know you were on grindr and they might
um
they might have negative feelings about
you as a result of that so this is not a
tool that where we want to connect with
friends rather we want to connect with
strangers than we actively people
actively don't want their um they
actively don't want their friends not
not universally true but very very
frequently in our data
oops
and not only that but
users want to be
grinders useful when when users are
unlikely to be identified by others who
are around them that is i don't want
people to know who i am necessarily but
i still want to appear attractive and so
we have this tension that they have to
balance in terms of how do i choose a
photo that's going to make me look good
but not make me look like a
essentially and how do i use language
that's going to frame me as somebody who
is socially good and useful just in case
somebody else sees me
or you know i may genuinely be just
looking for friends or dates but i still
don't want people to to see me there so
the way that we think about the utility
of tools and the way that we think about
um
you know who do we want to connect with
is a little bit different when a tool
like this because we are explicitly
looking for
strangers but strangers who are new who
are nearby and trying to present in a
way that's attractive sometimes drawing
on locations sometimes drawing on
descriptors for body type and so on and
using language to identify in particular
ways to appeal to a particular community
let's listen one
the second lesson
is the grinder in some very interesting
ways because it's using location but
because it's also sort of a place in and
of itself
it creates these interlocking layers of
places and identities if you want to
think about it that way so let me show
you a diagram so i'm showing you
bloomington indiana partly because i
gave a talk about this work there once
upon a time and partly because it's
actually pretty useful because
bloomington's a small town kind of in
the middle of nowhere in indiana
and so on the one hand if you you know
in bloomington you might be in downtown
bloomington
and if there are a lot of people around
the area encompassed by the set of
grinder profiles might be about that big
sometimes maybe on a weekend night etc
but at the same time it's not always
that densely populated so sometimes when
you log into grinder and bloomington
you're going to see people from all
around the surrounding area
but grinder's going to look
fundamentally the same even though
you're capturing very different people
and you've kind of got to be cognizant
of that
there's also this sense in which grinder
is a space on its own where people are
talking to each other you can be seen
there you cannot be seen there and that
has implications and then within that
there are conversations that are going
on and those conversations are not
visible to other people's you really
have no idea what other people are doing
you might have some guesses about what
other people are doing what they're
looking for etc but until you have a
one-on-one conversation with somebody
you have no idea what what anybody else
is doing in this space there's a sense
in which there are these sort of
parallel or sort of
lower level spaces that occur within it
but those are occurring from real places
you could be at starbucks you could be
at the bar you could be at a bath house
and those real places are going to have
impact on what's going on in those
conversations
and at that point the set of grinder
profiles around you doesn't necessarily
matter if you're talking to somebody
who's nearby and they're in one place
and you're in another um
you're talking to each other and you're
affected by your your context but what
really matters is the is the space in
that conversation and so at that point
the real world doesn't even matter and
so because we just have these
conversations that are happening in
these sort of sub-level spaces so that
was a lot to say
but there's but my point is um
that there's this layering that happens
where
the online space becomes a place
on top of this global sp they're the the
sort of general local area of
bloomington and then there are subspaces
within that that matter and this becomes
really complicated in terms of well how
do i present myself how do i interact et
cetera and so i think what it mean one
of the things it means is that we really
need to think differently
about anonymity
and
location when we're talking about apps
that are connecting strangers
essentially and there are a number there
are a number of ways we can we can do
that that i'm going to come back to
later
okay
so that's one set of studies now let's
move on to something else so let's come
back to this notion of anonymity and so
i was saying earlier
that once upon a time sherry turkle
wrote this book life on screen where
people were experimenting with identity
they were doing all this great stuff and
from a psychological standpoint we would
talk about this as positive
disinhibition right we talk about this
as the idea that people are experiencing
um
freedom essentially
to talk about taboo topics to explore
stigmatized identities because other
people don't know who they are they feel
some freedom to do this in ways that
they might not um if they were in a
named environment
and then what we actually and but but as
i also said people don't really do that
anymore so when you go on facebook you
have to use your real name to some
controversy and beyond that we know that
people
don't for the most part so mary morris
has done some nice work looking at the
kinds of questions that people ask their
peers on social networks people for the
most part don't ask about sensitive
topics on named social networks they
don't ask about sex they don't ask about
drugs they don't ask about health issues
they tend to go to search engines for
those as far as we um as far as we know
um
but now what we're seeing as some of you
are no doubt aware
are some tools that provide people with
anonymity locally so yik yak is a
noteworthy example of this
um but of course if you read the press
on yik yak it is for the most part very
very very negative yak yaki's evil
because it's allowing people to be
anonymous um and evil and what this
shows and i'll say more about this what
this shows is that i mean the primary
lesson from yik yak i think really is
the local anonymity is different because
it's not just your screen name but as we
saw with grinder profiles where somebody
could recognize your face
even though your name wasn't there on
yik yak somebody if
if i say oh james he's an idiot um all
of you know who james is none of you
know who i am if i've said this on yik
yak and so i can identify somebody in
the real world without having people
know who i am um so anybody might know
who i'm talking about even though they
don't know me
and in fact the um
the new yorker
after i titled the talk i should say
actually ran an updated version of their
cartoon where it says remember when on
the internet nobody knew who you were
and in fact if you look at the press on
yik yak like i said it's negative it's a
lot of cyber bullying it's people um or
at least what they believe is happening
is that people are picking on each other
and this is the opposite form of
disinhibition this is negative
disinhibition right this idea that
people are free from accountability
they're free from responsibility and so
they might behave in positive ways but
they might behave in negative ways they
might be mean to each other because
nobody's gonna punish me and because
nobody knows who i am right
and so
as we thought about this okay there are
bad things happening on yik yak and
other tools like it i will not deny that
but at the same time we know that there
are positive effects of anonymity too
positive disinhibition so we wondered
are people using tools like this and we
were thinking we started thinking about
this before there was yik yak so i'm
going to be jumping back in time a
little bit
but are people using these tools to seek
information about stuff that's local so
that where you wouldn't necessarily want
to ask google
about stuff that's local but anonymously
so we wanted to know what does
information
seeking look like in anonymous
anonymous location aware tools and so to
do that one of our one of my grad
students madeline smith um brought what
at the time was the northwestern
confessions page a lot of these have
gone away have how many have
participated in these
there is a stanford one but i'm not
friends with it um
so apparently i can't see it but as far
as i can tell most of these are not um
most of these are not very active
anymore because yik yak has sort of
taken over
but for those who have not seen these
confession pages it's an interesting
appropriation of a facebook page
essentially so what happens is that
somebody deems themselves the moderator
they will start a page such as
northwestern confessions
they will
create this page and in parallel create
a web survey so via surveymonkey or
something like that where they can um
where other people can sign in
anonymously fill out the surveymonkey
survey
submit a confession in this case a bit
of information whatever then the
moderator gets that and posts it so
here's what it looks like so what you
get are posts that are by the moderator
who just logs in as northwestern
confessions who they actually are as a
subject of much debate this is not a
particularly controversial one
but what's interesting is that the
response mechanism is actually people's
real names on facebook so anybody can be
viewing these
the real names are there i've crossed
them out so you can't see them um but
people can comment with real comments
and so what we see is a really
interesting mix
of anonymity where people can post stuff
anonymously take advantage of positive
disinhibition maybe um but people are
responding with their names and so there
are a couple questions here right one is
are people doing this constructively
so are people posting things that are
that are useful are they getting useful
information
and are the responses they're getting
because they're named first of all are
people hesitant to post about
potentially sensitive topics i may not
want to share my experience about
certain things with you if you know who
i am um or are they actually getting
responses
and if they do
are those responses actually useful
right so we set out to answer these
questions looking at facebook
confessions
so most of these pages apart from the
stanford one very exclusive
most of these pages are actually
publicly visible to anybody who signs
into facebook so we picked 35
universities 35 colleges and
universities from the us news
lists
and we basically pulled all the publicly
visible posts from these using the
facebook graph api 35 universities gave
us about 90 000 or so posts we also
pulled about 400 000 comments on those
um as i said we were interested in
information seeking so the way the first
pass way that we did that was to say
okay let's look for people asking
questions and that allowed us to draw on
some work on social question asking that
had been done before
um and so as a very simple crude filter
of well what's a question we just used
is there a question mark that's not part
of a url query string that actually
worked pretty well about 80 of the
things that we identified um using that
were actually questions in a in some
sampling in a sample
um
and so
and oh and i should give credit to nick
marola who is um who was a postdoc of
mine when we did this work now he's at
facebook
ironically both of us presented this
paper at kai last week even though the
both of us are at facebook now we were
both involved in presenting this work
that uses totally unauthorized data
okay so we checked those 15
um we took those fifteen thousand
questions we didn't know enough to be
able to automatically code these with
the grinder profiles we had some sense
of what we were well looking for um in
this sense we didn't in this case we
didn't we we were looking for sort of
nuanced constructs so we actually hand
coded these we did not code hand code 15
000 of them though we um we took a
random sample of about 3 000 there were
some mistakes so we wound up with 2803
we coded them for the types of questions
that people were asking we coded them
for the presence of taboo topics stuff
like sex drugs um medical issues there
were some others that comes from old
psychology literature and discussions
with our our ras and also evidence of
stigmatized identity and this work comes
from goffman that we had to we had to
update it but that's a whole nother
story um and then we looked at comments
we took a subset of um not quite four
thousand
um not quite four thousand comments
that were from about 481 questions and
these were coded for whether the
response seemed viable or not the people
were anonymous so we couldn't ask them
if the response was viable so we decided
to see if it was it was on topic and
seemed like a reasonable answer to the
question we were interested in whether
there was cyber bullying so we looked at
whether there seemed to be negative
language in the responses we also look
for evidence of taboo topics in the
responses themselves
okay that's the data let's see what we
um let's see what we saw
so the first thing that we're interested
in is well were people asking questions
at all and yeah they were they asked a
lot of questions um trust me so then
were they asking about sensitive topics
and the answer is yes
um so in terms of taboo topics which is
the main thing i'm gonna i'm gonna share
with you about 33 about a third of the
posts contain some kind of taboo these
percentages that i'm showing you here
are relative from that set
so
um
oh
i'm ahead of myself so
the the first told you i might mess up
the um the first thing we were
interested in was what type of questions
were people asking so they did ask
questions and um so in terms of the
types of questions that people asked
about half of them were opinion
that is to say so here's an example what
do women think about guys who smoke weed
turn off turn on neutral
so people generally just asking for an
opinion on some issue such as this one
about 37 of them are rhetorical um often
arguably these were seeking attention we
don't have evidence of that
but things like why can't i ever feel
pretty the guys always go for my friends
um
about that was another substantial
portion and most of the rest of them
were about um what we call factual
knowledge questions that is trying to
seek a discreet piece of information um
so and this one is nice because it is a
very local example so somebody says can
anybody tell what happened today near
university drive around 8 15
um a way of getting very specific very
local information
and that of course is a fact all right
this is where i thought i was so did
people ask questions about sensitive
topics yes they did um about a third of
the um post 32 percent contain taboo of
some kind a lot of that these are
relative percentages again a lot of that
was about sex so for example this person
says i know for a fact that name of this
town to protect him or her has orgies i
want to join a swingers club or
something similar can anyone point me in
the right direction
um
there were also a number of posts about
what we called protected groups which
can be a sensitive topic to discuss
you may have experienced this recently
with events in baltimore right and what
we call protected groups where basically
any group that in the u.s cultural
context could conceivably have some sort
of legal protection against
discrimination so things like religion
race gender
sexual orientation etc um and
these posts were interesting because
they tended to spark a lot of
conversation i'll see more about that in
a couple minutes
and sometimes they were relatively
mundane like this what do i guys think
of hispanic girls i feel as though they
just look right past us other times they
were very much about the experience of
um being a minority on a particular
campus for example
reaching out for friends other people
like them etc
um and then about eight percent of the
posts were about drugs or drug use um
some of the a lot of them were about
marijuana um and a number of them were
about adderall as in this case so this
one this person says does anyone in the
library have adderall i'll be in the
blank floor map room at 9 pm
so one way to solve a social
coordination problem
and get a potentially valuable resource
whether this is socially useful or not
i'm not going to comment on
but it is an interesting use of an
anonymous technology to connect with
people who are very local right
very pragmatic they get points for that
um other taboo topics that made up less
of the of the sample included
socioeconomic status and personal
finance medical issues mental health
death and dying bodily functions a lot
of bodily functions
so then the question is okay people are
asking about these things but remember
the responses are named so were people
actually responding to these
and the answer again is yeah
people are in fact responding to these
threads um and so what we did was to run
some regression models basically to
predict whether or not a post got
response or not based on its topic and
for taboo topics we compared them to
posts that didn't contain taboo that is
to say um we said is a post about sex
more likely to get comments than a post
with no taboo in it drugs etc and so i'm
going to give you a few highlights the
details of the tables are complicated in
the in the paper we can talk about them
later but a few highlights so one is
that and this is interesting one is that
a i think it's interesting anyway uh one
is that posts about protected groups
were more likely to get comments than
those with no taboo and this is not on
the one hand it's not surprising because
this is a relative well this can be an
uncomfortable topic to discuss it's not
one where you'd necessarily not want to
reveal who you are in discussing it
unless you're going to say something
particularly racist or vehement or
controversial but for the most part you
could you could imagine having
constructive discussion about this with
somebody who posted an anonymous query
etc and this actually led to and there's
an example of this at stanford there's
one at northwestern that i'll show you
in a few minutes these these confession
pages actually led directly or
indirectly to some universities setting
up anonymous pages where these issues
could be discussed
um i'll come back to that but these
these are actually more likely to get
responses
um
posts about drugs tended to get a lot of
likes um but the the which for better
for worse but the um but the number of
um the number of comments was not
significantly different from posts with
no taboo
um and posts about sex were actually
less likely to get likes but again in
terms of comments there was no
statistically significant difference
from those with um
with no taboo so what this suggests
overall is that while there were a few
differences for the most part the fact
that these contain taboo or sensitive
topics did not on the whole mean that
they were less likely to get comments in
particular yeah question
can you say again like
how much uh on average each post gets in
terms of comments do people comment much
at all
it's a good question i don't have the
numbers in front of me um but
essentially essentially it looks sort of
bimodal there are a lot of zeros um and
then the ones that do tend to get a lot
um but the but the mean is on the i mean
the mean which isn't terribly meaningful
but is on the order of five per um five
comments and maybe 14 or 15 likes if i'm
remembering right
so and that's partly just a function of
visibility of any given post yeah
question i wonder if these questions got
answered in other posts so if it's a
sensitive subject that i might not want
to comment but i might go through that
survey again and respond yeah so
interesting point and so that raises two
things one is that some of these are
actually set up where you can respond
anonymously as well we didn't look at
those um because we wanted everything to
be configured the same way two is we did
see some evidence of that um but but we
also saw a lot of response to the um to
the items themselves within the within
the facebook comment thread so you're
right that there was um there was some
of that and we don't we don't control
for that here
but in terms of the name responses which
is what we're which is what we're
looking at but yeah that i mean this is
one of the things we'd like to do as we
continue to to play with this data set i
mean the problem of course is that
nobody uses these things anymore so it's
there's some question about how how
useful it is to keep to keep looking at
them but it's a good point
um so then there's the question of okay
they got responses great were the
responses useful and were they um were
they negative in a in a cyber bullying
evil sort of way um and the answer is on
the whole no we found very little
evidence of um negative language in
these posts so about not quite 80 of
them were plausibly relevant or on topic
so here's an example of one so
somebody this is a real question but
there's not really a random university
this person says are there any athletic
sports um fitness movement based clubs
that i could join with little experience
in chronic illness and fatigue problems
and somebody posts whose name is not
really john smith yoga but this is a
real response yoga might be a good start
or maybe some light climbing
it's not a club but i hear the climbing
community is welcoming and friendly good
luck and they got some other responses
like this so people are getting very
legitimate
responses to these questions
and they're potentially locally relevant
as well
in terms of negative
language only about five percent of the
posts and this is not terribly
surprising given that people's real
names are attached to these
but we still wanted to see whether this
was um whether this was constructive or
not
okay
third study so let's talk about a few
lessons from this then a couple lessons
overall and then let's um let's have
let's talk a bit and we will have plenty
of time to do that which is great
um so first of all one lesson from this
is that even though people were seeking
information anonymously they were doing
so fairly constructively they were
seeking local information some
reasonable fraction of the time
and they were doing it they really were
doing it on sensitive topics about a
third of the time i didn't tell you the
results for stigma for time reasons but
about 10 of the posts contained
stigmatized identities i could also say
so they were talking about things that
were sensitive
and so what we think is that anonymity
was used constructively
and not for the most part negatively
which is
interesting again given the given the
press um and as i hinted so a number of
campuses have actually started pages
like these so this one's called stanford
class confessions
um
have people seen this i'm curious
apparently a resounding success um but
maybe for other for different audiences
um but so a number of universities have
started these for discussing
tensions between for example
socioeconomic class issues um racial
dynamics etc on campuses um which
is interesting in and of itself
um and in terms of a couple bigger
picture lessons so one is that there's a
lot there's been a lot of railing
against anonymity lately and i think one
one very useful point of this is to not
count that out and also to not say oh
people just go to search engines for
sensitive topics well if people are
given the opportunity to
shed their identity temporarily and seek
information they might do that
especially if they know they're going to
get information that is locally relevant
so we don't necessarily want to count
out yeah
so
what i'm inferring is that there's
something important about this um i
don't know what you call it unequally
where the questioner is anonymous but
not to answer it i'm wondering
is that the implication of where it
works versus let's say your jack or
something is a secret um so i would like
to believe that that's true i can't
prove it we are working on i'm going to
say in a couple minutes we're working on
yik yak now
um and so we want to see how that looks
different i mean there are a whole bunch
of things that are conflated in that
analysis so it's really tricky
but this does seem to be particularly
useful in that regard
i mean then you get into questions of
well what responses are we not seeing um
i mean you would certainly think you're
gonna get some filtering that's going on
but you're showing it doesn't totally
shut off
the conversation which seems important
right exactly and so yeah i mean i would
i would love to be able to say more
conclusively that yes that's exactly
what's happening um because we don't
have a it's really hard to compare this
to to anything else very concretely
um it's a really hard argument to make
concretely but i think that this plays
an important role i mean based on based
on what i've seen i also think social
norms play a big role and so getting
that balance down is is tricky
but but yeah generally
um okay
so
talked about three different studies and
so one of the things that i think ties
these together
is that we've heard a lot lately and we
were talking about this a bit at lunch
with some of the hdi grad students
there's a lot of we've heard a lot
lately about how content gets made
visible that is to say if i put
something online who else gets to see it
there was a lot of controversy around
the um
around the facebook news feed last
summer for example when facebook did the
release the emotional contagion study
that my colleague jeff hancock was very
involved in
and people got upset
in part
we've learned because
it turns out nobody understands how
facebook news feed works um a lot of
people believe that facebook was just
showing you everything um and so when it
came when it turns out that facebook is
manipulating the news feed people
realize they um they thought that
facebook was messing with information
that they would have had of course
most of you probably know
that the news feed is curated and
facebook is manipulating it constantly
every day so that they can sell you ads
so that they can show you things that
they think are important but most people
don't know that
and so we can think of that as a type of
what i want to call a visibility
mechanism that is a way that content
gets made visible in this case it's one
that's very confusing right because if i
post something i posted a status update
this morning i have no idea who saw it
and based on michael bernstein's work
with others at facebook i'm not likely
to be very good at estimating who saw it
so this is a very tricky
type of visibility mechanism
in contrast grinder uses a really simple
visibility mechanism um
that is it makes me visible to those who
are around me um do i know perfectly
who's gonna see it no because it depends
how many other people are logged in do i
have some idea that if somebody's 50
feet away then they sign into grindr
they're pretty likely to see it yeah
and do i think about that as a grinder
user or do our participants i should say
yeah they do they're very conscious of
who else can see their stuff and they
like that
and so we can think about
some key direct parameters and what i
think these studies and these these ways
of thinking about anonymity
identifiability and the way that they
intersect with location is that we can
start to think about some key parameters
for how stuff gets made visible
in um in social tools that we're using
to interact and connect with others in
different ways and so we can think about
the degree to which the tool itself is
transparent about how it's making
information available where the facebook
news feed is not transparent at all
it's not telling you very much about
what's going into the decision to
release your information or is grinder
is much more transparent yik yak is much
more transparent
facebook confessions fairly transparent
though you know they probably didn't
anticipate us reading them
so not entirely
you can think about the amount of
control that people have so one of the
reasons that i think the facebook study
last summer was so upsetting to people
is because they realized they really
didn't have control
um even though they may have thought
they did they may have thought that well
if i log in a lot i will see everything
or people tend to think in sort of folk
ways that they might have indirect
control well if i follow this person or
if i like all their posts etc i'm going
to see more stuff from them is that true
probably do we really know no
but we have this sort of notion of
control that's that's indirect that may
or may not be correct and so we can
think about the ways that we have
control over these mechanisms and again
with grindr this is fairly simple i can
block you or i cannot block you and you
will see me or you will not um it's a
lot less nuanced but it's simple i get
it
um think about the visibility of the
audience that is how do you know who can
see you so in grindr again you can see
who your audience is
um and like that quote that i told you
where the guy's like if i see somebody
on my in my dorm i want to block them
right away well he can do that because
he knows who saw it because you see
everybody who's around you and they can
see you and there's some reciprocality
there in terms of visibility
is that true on a system like facebook
no is that true on yik yak
sort of you know who sees stuff based on
who posts but really you have no idea
apart from the fact that you're you know
that your audience is local i mean think
about it in terms of that and then the
ways that people are identified facebook
of course uses names grinder uses photos
and there's varying degrees of
flexibility there so grindr you have a
lot of freedom because you could choose
a blank photo you could post a photo of
your face your torso somebody else's
torso
whatever you want at some level facebook
tries to enforce this policy of real
names which seems to get into trouble a
lot
but
but there's there are constraints on the
ways that people are identified and this
has effects for identifiability too
right if i see your real name um then
it's pretty easy for me to figure out
who you are in the real world if i just
see your photo i kind of have to have
some idea of who you are we need to live
in a pretty small community um so like
that guy who was the first person to to
to be to be new in town in a while where
he was drawing a lot of attention he was
identifiable not as a person but as a
new person and so there are a number of
ways that we can that we can be
identified so a couple relevant studies
that we're doing right now that i want
to tell you about and then we can then
we can talk about this stuff more
so one
is this idea of well given that people
are using location information to
present themselves in tools like grindr
what role does location information play
in impression formation
so colin fitzpatrick who i mentioned
before has mocked up this really nice
mobile app that essentially works like
tinder except that rather than just
looking at somebody's face you're
looking at a history of where they've
been um in evanston and he's asking you
would you want to work with this person
would you want to go on a date with this
person would you want to be friends with
this person this gives us a mechanism
essentially to go yes no to exploit
something that participants have
probably already done even though they
might not admit it um and to get a sense
of well and he's going to be crossing
different faces so if there's an
attractive face you'll see it with all
the location history this is all the
factors are going to be um
cross balance so an attractive face is
not necessarily going to going to win
out necessarily and to see how these how
this combination of factors affects
people's impression formation process
for people who are around them with
information about where they've been in
a local place
we've also started looking at yik yak
we've got a bunch of data which
matthew huston who is a first year grad
student is deep within right now hoping
to get a cscw paper out of it
and we're looking at people's
motivations we're looking at whether the
behavior tends to be positive um
things and things of that nature trying
to get a sense of well how does yik yak
differ from facebook confession pages
and what is yik yak actually being used
for given that the press about it has
been so bad and our sense so far is that
it's not that negative it's mostly jokes
how many years yik yak or half
and admit it um yeah i mean it's not
negative on balance we're trying to see
if there's there's useful stuff going on
there oh yeah one more thing for those
considering graduate programs or who
have students who might be
evanston is lovely for a small fraction
of the year
we have
shouldn't have said that we have um we
have two grad programs one is joint in
communication and computer science which
is technology and social behavior and
then a program that's primarily in
communication and we'd be happy to um to
talk more about that as well i also want
to put up the names of the folks who
made this work happen both in terms of
their effort and collaboration and work
in the lab and also who made the made
their effort possible by paying for it
so thanks to them and to all of you for
listening and i would love to talk about
this more
yeah that's great
uh so i'm a grinder how consistent is
that behavior of like blocking everybody
you know like what percentage of people
get blocked due to that reason do you
happen yesterday uh i mean so our most
of the work on people's actual behavior
with grinder is qualitative because we
don't we don't have access to their data
obviously and they're pretty averse to
being researched it turns out um so we
that didn't that didn't come up a lot in
our um in our interviews
it was definitely something that people
talked about or having people talked
about that as part of a suite of
strategies that they were using to avoid
being recognized and so sometimes they
did that by not posting their face
sometimes they did that by blocking
people they knew sometimes they did that
by just using grinder at certain times
things like that there were a bunch of
general strategies that people were
using we don't have a good sense of the
the specific frequencies with which any
given one was used
yeah
like doxxing activity has is affecting
people's use of anonymous forms or
supposedly anonymous forms um as opposed
to you know things like facebook where
they try to use
how do you think that affects the
balance i think most people aren't smart
enough to realize that it's a
possibility um frankly um so i don't
actually think it's having i mean people
who are savvy are going to be smart
about that but that's a tiny fraction of
the population so on the whole i think
it's having very little effect um and i
mean that's why we're seeing all the
crap that we see right um so i don't i
i think people are slowly getting
smarter but very slowly the the rate at
which they're getting stupid is much
faster than the rate at which they're
getting slower um smarter i would argue
about about that specifically um and
with the ra i shouldn't say the rate at
which they're getting stupid the rate at
which the use of these tools increases
and these apps spread out is much faster
and that's a better way to answer that
question
we've got lots of times
yeah
the question um
with like uh sort of the knowledge to be
recognized on writer so can you see
profiles on there without having to
grind your account
ah so that's a good question you can you
need to log into grinder and have an
account but that but grinder requires no
identifying information so you could
have um you could have an account
without a pick without a name without
any stats and you see these all the time
they're just blank um and so you you
could you could download it and log in
right now and you would see if anybody
in the room is on um and they would have
no idea that it's you that can see them
um so so that's what they're that's part
of what they're afraid of
yeah i was wondering have you looked at
the role of moderators and
pages like the confessions pages because
you talked a little bit about community
norms but there's also the big role of
maybe people put out the comments that
were offensive and then a moderator just
can't delete it
um so that's possible um we so okay so
there so let's let's back up a step
there are a couple places where
moderation is happening here right so
one is in the post itself because the
moderator's the one actually posting
that
um like i said the the person who is the
actual moderator of any given page is a
closely guarded secret which we could
not um which we could not parse
um so we did not ask about that process
our sense based on looking at the
comment at the content is that there's
not a ton of moderation going on because
some things did make it through that
were
either about sensitive topics or a
little bit inflammatory so there's
probably not a ton of that going on in
terms of comments being deleted we were
looking at this retrospectively so we
couldn't um couldn't account for that
our sense from watching the page on our
campus and a few other campuses is that
that's not happening a lot
um and again i think this role of as
james was saying this notion of
having your real name attached makes
particularly in a community that you're
a part of like you don't want to be my
strong suspicion is that people don't
want to be that person who said you know
something really offensive in response
to a comment because everybody knows who
you are
um and so my sense is that that's not
happening a lot but it is something that
we could look at it's a good a good
question
yeah
those nine percent of comments asking
for drugs uh oh wait no
not all of them are asking for but yes
um
like did the anonymity of the comment
system prevent them from getting their
fix
that's a fair question but you could i
mean so um we don't know because they're
anonymous um there were okay so the so
the drug posts took several forms so
some of them were just discussions of
you know attitudes toward drug use or
you know things like that in those cases
i don't particularly around like
marijuana and things that are um
not necessarily
terribly controversial in all areas so i
think people were i think people felt
much freer to comment on topics like
that
um would somebody respond to you know
does anybody have adderall probably not
but
you know does that mean they didn't find
each other no they probably they
certainly they could have
um or you could or i mean the other
thing we saw and this was lesson posts
about drugs and more in things about sex
and um death and mental health and some
of these other things is people would
respond in a way that didn't incriminate
themselves so that you could say
something like i've heard of things like
this or my friend had a situation like
this and you might want to try this
without saying like oh yeah that was me
um
so so there were ways that people got
around it for some bits of information
you know it would be harder to do that
for yes i have adderall um which i do
not um
so so yeah it's an i mean so that makes
that mix does become really interesting
in those cases yeah
whether your group has research or
you've read other research that might
speculate on
differences in the results that you find
with grinder with the derivative of
tinder
that might be relative to it being a gay
community versus not like are there
differences that you would see in the
behaviors and so which things might
apply broadly and which might be
yes i don't know of anybody who has um
who has done work on tinder
um but they're i mean so
i mean so the most fascinating thing to
me about tinder is that is the the
differences in the way that it's
structured
where you can't so on grindr you can
talk to anybody
and anybody can talk to you on tinder
you actually um as some of you may know
um you can't talk to anybody until you
both match so that is until you've both
swiped right on each other which to me
is what is the reason i mean so a number
of people tried to create so grinder
took off around 2009 in a way that no
tool for the straight community
did until tinder basically and my
argument for why that is is because
if women are going to use a tool like
that to meet men they're going to
they're probably going to have more
concerns around safety security and
creepiness
and tinder essentially gets around that
by at least making i mean you're not
going to get around all of that but at
least you're going to find the people
who are talking you're talking to and
who are talking to you attractive
um and so so in terms of the behavior i
mean grinder also comes out of a
historical context in the gay community
of anonymous sex
that for the most part has not existed
to such a strong degree in the straight
community and so that's part of why apps
like grinder i think were successful
um so and and a reason why a lot of
lessons don't apply but in terms of
stigma
how many of you are on tinder and admit
it
okay
so
i'm betting more of you are um so in
terms of you know some of the stigma
associated with it i think there is some
there i think tinder has been i think
tinder is a little bit less known for
hookups than is grindr
which is probably part of that but it
would but in terms of um in terms of
actually doing a more rigorous
comparison it would be i would love to
see somebody do that it would be a great
thesis
it's interesting that the grinder like
enabled this kind of like location-based
hookup culture by making it anonymous
and in a way i mean as you're saying
because of issues with safety first like
i think in this great community like
tinder is as close as there is to like a
core hookup app
right and they enable that by not making
it not not making it anonymous like you
have mutual friends you have facebook
connections you have you know education
information like yeah
um
is there a prostitution component to
tinder
i always wondered but there's got to be
business models associated with this
we have heard from people who have got
gotten prostitution solicitations
um via tinder
um so i would guess that that but they
but but you have to have so tinder you
have to authenticate via facebook
um and it shows you the i mean trivial
yes um but it also shows you mutual
friends it shows you shared interests
and so on and so
some people so for some people they may
be especially on a college campus like
the probability that you're going to
have mutual friends is high and so
prostitution yeah done that that lens or
whatever you could you could run a
business model underneath it
you could yeah i mean that's not that's
not something i mean so
yeah i mean that's not something that
we've looked at a lot because my guess
is that it's not happening a lot um and
it's that then it becomes less about
self-presentation and more about how can
we scam people to make money which is
which is le which is from from my
standpoint less interesting but but but
certainly it's theoretically possible
yeah that's
like a research methodology kind of
perspective how you deal with
technologies that are very rapidly
changing um so for example with yik yak
like a month ago they rolled out that
update where like you know the entire
thread used to be anonymous but now you
have like the randomized icon so you can
actually have a conversation
like
have some type of identity and then like
this week they will have base camp where
like now you can be remote and you know
it doesn't have to be location based so
does that force you to like very quickly
change your research question or how
you're going about that um
not really because i mean ultimately
we're interested in broader i would
argue we're interested in broader
behavioral phenomenon as they play out
online um in a particular context and
under a particular set of design
constraints and so we take the so like
facebook confessions for example were
used very heavily when we grabbed our
data um we analyzed the data and now
they're not used anymore but did we
learn something from that yeah we did um
especially from this particular
configuration of stuff that that turns
out to be useful probably and ditto with
yik we grabbed a bunch of data a few
months ago we're going to analyze that
data and describe it you know
as being gathered when yik looked like
this
um and you know might that look
different when yik yak looks like
something else yeah it might but would
we still learn about how people behave
under particular circumstances yeah we
would
and that's ultimately what's useful i'm
not doing market research for yik yak so
i don't really um i'm less interested in
having the most up-to-date version of
their feature than i am and having a
good data set
yeah
these are newer um like hook up slash
meeting apps are like utilizing facebook
login like friends lists and that those
kinds of things as information you get a
sense of like how useful uh those
usually they're they're using those like
like the mutual friends notions that
like helping them and that kind of thing
eric generally for the safety reasons i
was mentioning earlier my strong
suspicion is yes it's um it's absolutely
helping them because it helps overcome
issues of creepiness and safety um
particularly in a in a within a
community where people are likely to
have overlapping social ties
um
in terms of grindr they don't do any of
that so we and that's what we have data
on so we i can't say that that
conclusively and i mean it's also true
that and i suppose you could make the
reverse case that where people are
particularly concerned about being
recognized and so forth um well no even
in that case it would be useful because
if i don't want people to know um and i
see you and we've got a ton of friends
in common swipe left right
um
so there's
so it would be interesting to look at
and get people's perceptions of um we
have not done that yet and i again i
would
somebody needs to study tinder um maybe
it should be us i don't know um but i
would love to see some comparative stuff
on that so we could say some of the
stuff better yeah
um what do you want to do with this data
or like see see down with this data
besides just analyze it and know these
patterns
oh well so like i was starting to get at
the end what i'm what i'm ultimately
viewing this as useful for is having a
way to understand how people engage with
each other and how what are the
challenges in self-reasoning so we we've
tended to think about um we've tended to
think about identity and
self-presentation online in a not very
nuanced way because we were either we've
tended to say we're either anonymous or
not
and that kind of worked for a long time
because we were either anonymous or not
but i guess part of my point and part of
the point i'm trying to make here is
that well now that we are interacting
with people who are right around us the
notion of identity and how we might
identify ourselves and how we might be
identified is very very different and so
if we're going to design tools to help
people connect to each other well would
we necessarily think that tools are
going to be most useful when your
friends aren't using them but strangers
are maybe not
would we necessarily think that you know
a combination of anonymity and
identifiability is actually useful for
for seeking information
especially when that information is
local well we might not and so it's it's
bringing insights into how we think
about when different different types of
different types of identity and
identifiability and the way that that
might impact design and the way that we
think about sort of characterizing
online spaces and people's interactions
in those spaces
design and design philosophy and yeah i
mean some combination of behavioral
theory and design philosophy um i would
like
online connection uh to promote better
well i mean online connection is one
thing but online information seeking
online
interactions more generally yeah
you